hello and welcome to another open source
chat this time we're talking about Cordo
with almost all of the chordo team so
first off what are open source chats uh
there are two big goals for open source
chats firstly to connect users of a tool
Cordo in this case directly with the
people who develop and maintain that
tool developers can sometimes feel a
little disconnected from end users it
may be not so much in this case a quarto
has something like 12 commits a day on
average for the past two years in a
pretty active issues and discussion
section but then you know users are
often unaware of how these open source
tools get developed get maintained and
so forth open source software just works
better the more active engage the
community is and the better the
connection there is between developers
and our end users secondly we'd like to
use this opportunity for you to share
with each other how you use quarto how
you approach and solve common problems
with that in mind we invited questions
from the community in this discussion
since this is a recorded video you
obviously won't be able to pose any new
questions but instead we invite you to
check out the quarto dev teams GitHub
discussion section see the video
description for details and with us
today we have Al Manning Al is quarto T
manager manager at the growing team at
Cordo
Carlos scheidegger software engineer and
recently previously out of Academia
Charles Teague software architect at
posit and as I understand it essentially
co-lead of the quarto project with JJ
Lair and then joining us a bit later is
going to be Isabella Velazquez who is
essentially editor-in-chief at positblog
as well as much else here she'll be
taking over duties about halfway through
the presentation because spoiler alert
I'll be having a few technical
difficulties
to get started off what is Cordo uh
quarto is an open source scientific and
Technical publishing system that builds
on standard markdown with features
essential for scientific communication
computational engines include python R
Julia and observable JS markdown that's
pandok with many enhancements output to
documents presentations websites books
blogs and much else as a first question
to get started I asked the group why
open source one thing that the three of
you I've noticed looking at your
backgrounds uh and the CVS that I could
find online there was an explicit
mention of your contributions to open
source software and yet Cordo and you
know joining posit that's kind of a core
to what we're doing and I I actually
know a few of you were making
contributions to OS before but that
wasn't kind of a core thing to your
occupation where it is now so I kind of
would like to pose that to you
um so maybe if I could start with Al why
open source why have you decided to to
work in open source oh wow
um I I have to try to keep my answer
short because uh we we don't have that
much time
um I I've I've been um primarily
involved in close in in sort of private
Company software engineering for a very
long time
um and this was
um I've been involved before open source
and um I've experienced what it was like
as a developer to be vendor locked and
forced into doing large-scale updates
based on my relationship with a
particular vendor and I also saw what
happened as your open source movement
and basically changed my graph
um it completely transformed the way
that I work the communities that I was
involved in really uh really
um uh uh an important sort of uh aspect
to how I've grown as a developer and so
when I had an opportunity to really join
in and do open source development I was
very inspired
um also by the mission of the the
company uh and how open source is such a
close part of um what the mission is
I've yeah as Carters mentioned I'm a
recovering academic I used to be a
professor in computer science before I
joined uh uh our studio now pause it
um just about a year and a half ago and
this problem of uh sort of technical
communication of sort of creating this
mix of documents and computational
content in a way that's reproducible in
a way that's easily shareable that's
sort of most impactful and visible for
everyone so this problem has been near
and dear to my heart for easily 15 years
with sort of like the entirety of my
professional career and so when I had
the chance to to sort of work on a
problem like this with the team that had
built our markdown that had built sort
of like the standard solution for our
and in a way that is both open source
and is targeting sort of the broader
data science ecosystem for me it was a
very solution uh I was just like yes I
would do this uh can I find a way to
contribute in any way I can
and so that's sort of how I got
interested in open source and cuarto
specifically
and it's been fantastic so I've been
working uh for just over a year and a
half now so I wasn't around when the
project started but I've been around for
a while and it's been just a ton of fun
and Incredibly rewarding and I'm very
excited about what quarto is I'm going
to bring in the next few years a few
months yeah I mean I think I'll be brief
certainly a lot of the sentiment that
Alan Carlo shared was true for me as
well I think the one other dimension uh
for me individually was that um you know
I'm I'm quite
um inspired by the pursuit of improving
scientific communication uh and so
that's part of what attracted me to
Cordo was the ability to try to
facilitate better Technical and
scientific communication and to me the
foundation of that had to be open source
uh it was just simply something that was
required in order to make that
successful in those communities and to
support
um that type of communication really
broadly uh and so so to me it was sort
of um while I I'd seen the growth of
Open Source and really wanted to engage
in it I also saw it as essential uh to
the success of this project
um and and so I'm excited to be
contributing and doing that for the
first time
the first question I saw that came into
slido actually a couple days ago it was
actually a question that was posted to
the rlib
um issues asking about would Porto
actually end up on something like cran
or it's a bit uh easy to install for our
user is that something that's uh you're
thinking about or working on or is it
gonna likely to continue to be the kind
of thing separate way to you know
separately install the CLI for Porto
yeah I think um you know I think of
course quarto is built into our studio
so it's a it's distributable there
um there there is an r package available
for quarto specifically Cordo R uh and
so that's installable as well and so
it's we're certainly we have our our
goal is to make it really easy for our
users obviously to use Gordo um so you
know where where we're not doing so
um you know we we would like to do so
now that said you know uh Cordo you know
is a uses a typescript runtime use a
whole bunch of Technology uh under the
hood so it's not merely in our package
it's quite a bit more than that and so
you do need you know it it does need all
of that to be functional
um you know I saw that there was a
question specifically about supporting
um use of use of quarto in generating
vignettes and other things and I think
that that's a slightly different matter
um which is uh you know not something
that's entirely within our control
from from my understanding I think the
main issue there will be that there
should if we need to use it as if people
want to use it as an yet you need to be
able to actually have the full binaries
run in on Quran and uh main issue there
is it runs on a lot of architectures for
which we don't have a lot of control
like older architectures and principle
in particular because Dino is a
relatively new runtime so quarter is
built on Dino and Dino is a relatively
new uh system that probably doesn't have
a lot of support for older runtimes we
do a little bit of work on for example
older versions of scent OS but not on
the broad support that you need from uh
crayon so
um we would love to do something like
that but I think that will require the
kind of effort that we're currently
doing for other things at the moment so
I wouldn't count on that being around in
the next year for example thank you
there's a another question that was
echoed in a question on slider that was
echoed in the zoom chat as well from
John David Smith the question is one
nice output report I would be to produce
a Google doc the best current solution
is not great which is to create a dot
doc file and drop it into Google Drive
you have any kind of support for that
and it was echoed in Zoom because a lot
of teams right they work out of Google
doc share Doc in which we can work out
of well yeah thanks for mentioning that
I mean I think we've talked about
different formats and um in terms of you
know our uh you know future backlog
um and it's interesting to think about
Google doc and its relationship between
like a publishing format like something
like you would see with Confluence or an
actual DOC format I think we've talked
about it a little bit but not that much
and I too have used Google Docs and
quite a lot before so I I do think it's
something that's interesting for us to
look into in terms of the actual like
approach to publishing I'm not really
sure myself what the what the format
would be and how would we post it out if
it would be similar to what we're doing
the Confluence or something else but I
think it's a very interesting idea and
thank you for mentioning it
Carlos and Charles I don't know if you
have any thoughts on on Google Docs I we
would love to support it
um there's a certain amount of work
making sure that everything works uh
exactly how we would love a fully
supported sort of system for for Google
Docs and collaboration to do that in
like the right way so again that's the
kind of thing that we want to make sure
we do it right if if we're going to do
it so
um I don't think we have
short plans to to announce or anything
like this but it's it's certainly
something we would love to be able to do
so we we hear your uh your your pain and
we want to address it we
um we'll let you know when we have
something on that
um and so just sort of to follow up on
some of the solutions that people
suggested so some folks use track down
as a way to sort of export in and out in
a way that will let you do that and it's
not ideal but at least you can sort of
see the changes and you can actually
like pull it back and forth so there are
some workarounds but we we know they're
not ideal so we'd love to be able to do
something better we just don't have any
plans uh given the other things that we
need to do at this point
there's another question that I actually
heard echoed as well
um ahead of time
um the question from from Matthew
Markington asking about Lua filters and
short codes or blue filters and
shortcuts are amazing I'm interested to
hear from the quarto team their approach
uh working environment for developing
and Lua in a way that enables quickly
prototyping and debugging this iteration
is a point of friction from Matthew so I
100 agree with you given that I had to
essentially learn the well when I joined
the quarter project and I already joined
when there were hundreds of Lua files
and I agree with you that the law
experience is uh could be improved a lot
and we are actually putting a ton of
effort on this uh coming up so one of
the things that we have support for and
unfortunately it's only if you're using
vs code right now but you can actually
use uh if you're on if you're willing to
use a visual studio code which um it's
not our studio for example for like
developing Lua you actually have
um if you open sort of Lua files and
filters we have the ability of doing the
kinds of Auto completions that you get
from say like typescript right sort of
like type inference on tandock values
type inference on your functions and
sort of like reminding you that if you
open a file you need to check if the
file was open successfully and that kind
of thing and that helps a lot so uh we
should probably do a better job at
documenting how to get to that and
that's something we're working on on 1.3
but this kind of developer experience
for Lua specifically for sort of filters
short codes extensions so Charles has
put a lot of effort in 1.2 in providing
a really good solid support for
extensions and now in 1.3 we're sort of
making it nicely sort of usable in terms
of getting all of the intelligence that
you can get out of Visual Studio code
specifically
so that's how I develop
um so I would be if folks have questions
on that we can either like sort of open
a discussion on GitHub which cortis and
Isabel I can point out to where things
are or we can um have
um like reach out to me in other ways
and sort of try to figure out a way to
document this for people who are
invested we know it's an ask right now
it's sort of like you have to learn a
few other things and it's not trivial
but we actually actively wanted to make
it easier because it will be the way
that you develop quarter extensions for
the foreseeable future
I think the one other note to add there
would be I think starting in one two and
one point two of Cordo
um the preview server should now be hot
reloading if you're changing filters
inside extensions for example and so you
should be getting sort of the ability to
sort of modify filters and then see
reloading right there without having to
go through a whole render cycle again
um and I believe that was starting in
1.2 but that was something that JJ added
that made a huge difference in terms of
extension development and I think the
one other note that you know that that I
think is worth um throwing out there is
we've done a lot of the development of
the Lewis stuff as extensions and that's
a useful way to test as well because um
so you know obviously uh you know that's
one other thing to consider another set
of questions kind of feeds into a theme
that I saw Richard on slido edit asked a
few days ago is there a single
documentation page for all the quarto
specific piano options
um and I think the theme of that fits
into kind of documentation recorder like
the quarterdoc site is quite big is
there any kind of advice that you guys
have for people kind of engaging with
that
um and trying to kind of like dive into
those features
um it's both like a very strong point of
quarto it's incredibly well documented
but
um folks yeah are curious if there's
something more like a cheat sheet for
example or something like right so so we
don't have a cheat sheet and uh I would
love to do something like that given the
ones that you know our studio used to
put out for like our markdown and ensure
positive we'll do that for new libraries
we don't have one for quarter yet but
they'll be a fantastic one to work on
that's a great idea
um the problem so the question was about
a single web page with all the animal
references we would love to do something
like that we originally had considered
doing precise of that as a single page
the issue is quarto has a pretty big
surface so on last count there was like
on the order of a few thousand yaml
options that you could use to configure
um and that's not exaggeration is over a
thousand
um so we can't uh like it's not the
issue would be that people would miss
the forest for the trees right like it
would be hard to sort of see what's
going on on those
um we do have this I I posted on chat
it's sporto.org docs slash reference or
if you just go on the main quarter
webpage it's right on the main menu it's
reference so that is actually the option
to reference all of those are yamo and
so you can sort of get an entry point if
you want to do something for document
formats or for presentations for
markdowns for execution and start from
there and that you have the list of all
of those so if that's a good entry point
it is not a single web page but it's uh
relatively comprehensive and it's just
generated automatically from our yaml
infrastructure so that gets sort of
automatically updated so it's certainly
like up to date one thing that we've
heard around our documentation as well
is
um it may be uh it may be a bit
overwhelming in terms of how much there
is and how it covers everything very
comprehensively and very deeply
um and it may be interesting interesting
in taking a look at and creating
on top of the existing sort of full dock
set
documentation sets that are focused on
more specific cases and uses of Cordo so
this is something that um resonates with
you we would love to hear from you about
that
um as it's uh as uh Carlos said the
surfaces is massive and so it can be
difficult to know exactly how to come in
um and we also want to take into account
your contacts and your background
for entering in and using quarto
and if I could take a pause for a moment
there's a lot of good questions coming
in and I'd like to get to them but I
seem to be having a technical issue so
can I ask Isabella to take over the the
host position to kind of help things go
A bit more smoothly would you be able to
do that Isabella yeah hi everyone
I am happy to share some questions
there's really great ones coming in and
so I will just go down the line so from
chat uh we get loving quarto
and thank you Porto devs and absolutely
love the tool so OJs is a total win and
you work uh with duck baby it is great
is there something like observable SQL
cells on the roadmap
so um thank you for for asking that
that's a very good question
um to the best of my understanding the
sequel so a few folks don't know what
observable is just to backtrack a little
bit this is
um a new
javascript-like uh runtime for web pages
that offers reactivity sort of like what
you would get with react but sort of as
a lower level higher performance so you
can do really nice interactive
visualizations and it has a shiny feel
to it if you're in our shiny programmer
so everything is actually reactive and
so you don't need to set up event
handlers and things of that sort so it's
exceedingly nice and quarter has support
for the runtime for sort of like the
execution model for that uh observable
is built by observable HQ which is a
startup and they make the runtime open
source and so they've been generous
enough to do that and we are super
appreciative of that and sort of we use
that in quarto the SQL sell specifically
to the best of my understanding is not
open source that's part of their
value-add proprietary uh sell for sort
of navigate getting a database in
JavaScript in runtime and so they don't
offer that as part of their open source
offering so we can't use that with that
said we would love to sort of we have
the kind of like code we use that you
can get out of observable in general
sort of reusing notebooks so if you have
a web page in which you sort of have an
SQL navigator that you wrote you can
actually reuse it across we just don't
have access to the really exceedingly
nice SQL cell explorer.observable HQ
does and
I don't think we'll be able to because
it's not part of the open source
offering
another chat question from David
reinstein uh what is the best way to
retain data and environment objects
across chapters in a Porto book is there
any uh path to enabling this it's a main
thing from our markdown that David is
looking for in quarto
yeah I think I think the issue if I
understand it correctly boils down to
the fact that I think booked down sort
of conceptually renders the book as a
single large executable document whereas
Cordo renders them individually and so
there's not shared context between
individual Pages
um so you know I I don't I actually
don't know what the best solution to
that problem is I think you know uh the
one that jumps out to me straight away
is is includes and I don't know if
Carlos wants to weigh on in this but
simply you know creating that shared
context and setup cell in a in a file
that's included in every chapter and I
know it's not ideal to have to include
something in every chapter that's the
best thing that I can think of I don't
know if you have Alternatives Carlos so
um yeah so one of the Charles said um
this is another issue where the
difference between our markdown and
quarto sort of uh makes it particularly
painful for folks that are used to the
way that sort of are marked down and
booked downwards which was taking a
single document uh and running it all in
a single context which part of does not
do so Charles mentioned includes which
essentially are you can sort of just
pick uh sell and like put it on an
include document and then just run it
and someone mentioned on uh on voice
right now that that slows down because
you have to re-execute that every time
and so that's absolutely an issue uh one
of the things that uh you can do is sort
of unfortunately it's sort of manual but
you can introduce some State and check
whether you know your file exists and
sort of not run it and sort of just
return it from like a
for example an sqlite database or a data
frame and sort of do the management
yourself which is an additional pain
point it's not ideal but that's
something you can do the other thing you
can do and that's starting on version
1.3 is
um so this is something that just as hot
off the process and Charles worked on
this is we we can actually sort of run
things and pull results from an existing
notebook from an existing ibnb file and
so if you have a setup code that it
takes a lot of time you can sort of set
up a different quarter page and render
to a pi and B right so that the result
it generates is a notebook
and then we actually have a new short
code that is uh on the documentation
which means it's called the embed short
code which can pull parts of an existing
i5nb file without re-executing it so it
actually pulls it from the result uh and
so this works for any IPI and B whether
it was generated by quarter or whether
it was generated by yourself uh or you
know sort of from like an existing
jupyter notebook and it just works like
that and so if you have a pi MD file
that generates the result that you want
to pull to a different page that's a
very nice way of doing it now
it is not a straightforward to pull for
example data or things of that sort and
so it's not perfect but that's the kind
of solution that we're starting to work
on and sort of how to reuse existing
bits from other web pages and in this
case from notebooks that we would love
to sort of figure out the story and
currently we have the support for embed
but this more General sort of how to
manage dependencies in order of
execution is definitely something that
we would love to improve in quarter in
future versions we'll probably do some
work of that next year
we we are aware of the pain that this is
causing users we we want to work on it
but we want to make sure that this works
across specifically across not only our
markdown but users that come from a
Jupiter background and users that might
have like Julie execution cells and
things of that sort so it's a little
larger scope of a problem
excellent thank you so much
um so there is a lot of excitement about
Flex dashboard for Corda I'd love to
hear about
um yeah I'll just read the question from
Jake directly what are the plans for
Flex dashboard or replacement it's our
most common deliverable and not having
it has stopped us from sharing with our
team
uh well yeah I can I can speak to this
um we we don't have an official forecast
as a team so um and the main reason why
is we're uh we're trying to be very have
a lot of agility and adapt as
information comes in and we saw that
with 1.2 and 1.1 that
um as we were learning we really needed
to focus in on stabilization
um for the very beginning the team has
been talking about Flex dashboard
um and it's on our mind and we've had
recent conversations about it so it's
top of mind
um
in in terms of our
our forecast
um I don't know if Charles or Carlos
went to speak to any of the the planning
so far or anything
no I think the one thing I can say is it
has been Flex dashboard has been on the
road map since pre-10 so we I think we
originally set out and said okay when
oneo comes out this is gonna be great
it'll have to like it'll have support
for dashboards and then we're like okay
we didn't quite get that done for our
studio conf but for one one we'll
definitely dashboards for one two
dashboards uh you know so I think it's
it's it's right there we know it's
something that is uh necessary and we
just have not quite managed uh to get
there in terms of the work that we have
in front of us so uh you know I don't
think we we can commit to exactly when
that will be there except to say that we
know it's it's something that is
essential uh and it is sitting at the
front of of every time we talk about
what should we be doing it's sitting
right there with us go with you know
it's there in like one or two other
things that were like God we really have
to get to these things so I do I do
expect us to get there soon
awesome thank you
and it's not quite a question but I
would love to just hear your your
thoughts on this statement
um so someone on slido posted that the
biggest impediment for team adoption uh
with Porto is competing with IPython
notebooks for mindspace and just welcome
your thoughts on like
um yeah on that topic
uh well I mean I think ultimately we'd
love to see us as complimentary to
notebooks in in some capacity
um you know and so I don't I think
notebooks have an important role in um
data science and in science uh and so we
we don't Gordo doesn't need to supplant
that it can merely be an addition to it
but there are advantages to Gordo there
are capabilities that Cordo has that
notebooks don't have and so for
particular kinds of communication
you know I could I would highlight
things like um citations and
bibliographies cross-references uh you
know that type of feature is a feature
that is something that Cordo adds to a
notebook and so uh you could either you
know in The Notebook based world you
could say I'm going to write quarto
markdown in that notebook and use quarto
as an engine to render that notebook and
you'll get resolved citations and
references and cross-references and
you'll get all the the quote of goodness
on top of that notebook that's that's
one possibility uh you know as Carlos
alluded to we're working on embedding
resources from notebooks and so that
would let you take and use the quota
document as a narrative focused document
and so focus on narrative and layout and
appearance and embed the outputs of
computations that come from notebooks
right within uh right within your quota
document and so that lets you sort of
use the two as complementary to one
another
um and so I think you know uh you know
we have we have work to do to continue
to improve our notebook support but I to
me you know I think what we ideally
would see is that notebooks are yet
another tool Porto is another tool and
those tools are really quite
complementary to one another as opposed
to being substitutes for one another I
mean I don't know if Carlos you have
other stuff to add to that but that's
maybe at a high level
no I think that's I think that's exactly
right and um I
speaking from uh sort of you know I've
used to be a professor I mentioned this
earlier and a lot of my students when we
were doing research they were all using
notebooks and pytharch to sort of do
their machine learning experiments so I
shared the understanding of how
convenient folks find the notebooks to
be and one of the things that uh right
like Charles mentioned is sort of this
issue of
uh sort of complementarity and so write
the embed short code that Charles just
implemented is sort of going towards
that
um and one of the things that we can do
that maybe we should advertise more
broadly is we can use ipin BS as both
input and as output and wire in quarto
right so I'm not sure just sort of
making sure that folks are aware that
this is a possibility but if you'd like
type quarter or render and you give up
ipin and B we will convert that notebook
to like markdown we will do all the
processing and we'll produce all the
outputs that you need if you need to
produce an iPad ND file we also uh can
do that so you can take a qmd and you
can render try an iPhone so you can
share with people that are entirely on
the iPhone ecosystem and so
um I I understand sort of the trying to
convince folks uh of whether this is a
language agnostic tool or something
that's really from the our universe we
are working very hard to make sure that
this works well with folks existing
workflow in a company and their personal
workflows if there are specific things
that that our pain points I would love
to hear about them like either like you
know shoot me an email post a question
on GitHub we absolutely want to make the
IPython ecosystem work well in quarto
great and that kind of leads into the
next question so a specific one from
from slido uh jcast I'm not sure where
to post issues on GitHub is an issue
with the rendering button in our studio
something for the r Studio team or the
quarto team and then I guess more
broader like what is the best way of
getting in touch
um like what sorts of uh advice would
you give for for folks who want to reach
out I can answer that so
um
we are happy if folks are not sure where
to post a GitHub issue post it on our
repository if we don't think it's the
right place for it we will sort of let
you know we will help you figure out
where is the right place or that but we
would much rather hear from you folks
that are having issues that we want to
help then not hear about it because
folks have some hesitancy about where or
whether you're doing the right thing uh
we would love to to get everyone uh in
the discussions and so
um if you the main place where we have
discussions I think is available posted
on chat earlier is the discussions Forum
on the Quanto CLI repository on GitHub
um and the issues for that same
repository is where we do tracking of
all of the problems so if you want to
take that as an entry point for these
questions we would be happy to take
either and sort of figure out whether
it's in our studio issue or not so
please don't don't hold back on
reporting bugs from us which we do want
to hear because you're not sure where to
post them we would be happy to to figure
things out
awesome and in terms of the community
like what sorts of things would you um
hope to see in the future like projects
code contributions like how uh what it's
like yeah the most helpful and inspiring
for you
uh well so so Carl's pointed to issues
that's on issues are obviously helpful
because it's how court was actually
being applied and the scope of what you
can do with quarto is so big we need
people doing all kinds of crazy things I
personally am really uh interested to
see what people come up with for
extensions there's quite a bit of latent
capability in the extension ecosystem
and it's one of the things that I do
think differentiates Cordo from from
something like just pure pandok is the
ability to really bundle and extend the
capabilities a lot of what is built in
Cordo that you know that we built sort
of pre in the pre-10 world could
potentially be built as extensions now
um and we just didn't have that the
infrastructure at the time we were doing
quarter 10 so to me there's a huge
amount that people can do with
extensions and we would love to see
those extensions and promote those
extensions
um and then even um I think just today
um just this morning I merged a pull
request from somebody and pull requests
are of course always always welcome I I
unders stand and I want to acknowledge
it working on quarto is not necessarily
easy there's a lot of different
languages and a lot of different
runtimes and so just from a complexity
perspective there's a lot to take in but
even small simple PR's help
um and we've gotten a ton of those and I
I I certainly eminently really
appreciate uh that when people take the
time uh to make those PRS to to whether
it's a translation or whether it's a
code change it's really really welcomed
I'd just like to add to that that
there's a lot of very active members of
the community now who are supporting us
in issues in discussions and thank you
very much
um it is
um it is it's inspiring and I think
we're very grateful to have such an
Engaged community and we definitely feel
the booze
um so thank you
that's wonderful thank you
but there are a few questions in the
chat and the slido on um customization
with CSS being able to look at the
gallery examples and and
um you know make your website your blog
look the way that you'd like but any
kind of tips or or feature upcoming
features on making like that kind of
stylization uh easier
so one one that I will point to for one
three
um that we did and is available in the
one three builds right now it's not
super well documented but I think if you
find the release notes for one three
there's a link to some better
documentation one of the one of the one
great thing about Cordo is the grid
system that it has that sort of lays out
the page and lets you lay out different
elements and have sidebars and things
and that's a great thing about it that's
also a terrible thing about it because
it's quite opinionated about the size of
everything uh and so that's been a
challenge for us for people I think who
have different opinions about the size
of things not they don't share our
opinion uh so um in starting in one
three we've tried to make it a lot
easier for people to actually control
the grid system and call the size and
position you know not necessarily the
position but basically to say you know
how how what do you want your widths and
margins to be inside of our grid system
and that lets you make content wider or
make the sidebars smaller or make the
sidebar wider and we've got pretty
simple ways for you to configure those
things via either yaml or scss uh that
should Cascade through the grid system
uh appropriately so if people have a
chance to give that a spin you know I
found it makes a really big difference
for things like sidebars that have long
text or other other scenarios where you
really get sort of you get some pain
from the fact that Cordo has such strong
opinions about how narrow and wide
things need to be so that's a simple
um simple thing for people to play with
starting in one three aside from that I
I think the one other thing that um
Carlos just did that with that is fun is
extending our theme mean to mermaid
which is really nice for using mermaid
diagrams you won't if you're in a dark
theme you won't be confronted with a
glaring bright diagram but instead a
nice consistent themes diagram
so one of the things that we are working
on uh for 1.3 so so the mermaid theming
was one of those things as Charles
mentioned
is actually sort of documenting and
figuring out what are the CSS and scss
variables that are available in general
for a theme so other packages can use
them as well so we forward scss
variables to proper CSS variables so if
you're just producing on your own custom
JavaScript or your own custom python
output things like we know we're making
we're going through the trouble of
figuring out how to make those available
for you so they're themed automatically
and things of that sort
um rich I known who's the author of GT
who is the package for sort of producing
really nice tables has been working with
me on that so we're looking forward to
have the kind of like very nicely
integrated support for theming that will
work consistently sort of across
packages so that folks that are
authoring these can just actually
have a consistent look depending
independent of like the theme they chose
or the environment in which things are
executing so that's another place where
we think we can do better than we have
right now in CSS and so that's something
that we expect to have a number of
improvements already in 1.3 but we'll be
continually working on that
in one just one thing to note about the
one other note about the grid system
that's important to distinguishes
there's really two resources that you
you could use if you're really thinking
about the quarter grid system one is
just reading about CSS grid which is
what Cordo uses as a grid system and is
available you can just use CSS grid from
within Cordo
um then there's if you look on our
website under the documentation under
article layout you'll find essentially a
higher level grid system that we've
built on top of CSS grid that lets you
sort of dock things to different
positions in the page across the width
of the page it looks a little closer
like what you might see as latex
geometry so it looks a little more like
that and is a slightly higher level
thing that that is more constrained but
could be easier to use
um that does have the benefit of working
across platforms across output formats
and so many of those layout features are
available in PDFs as well as HTML
absolutely thank you so much
um so a quick terminology question so I
think that as when you are sharing your
work with normies what do you refer to
the HTML hosted quarto content you say
have a look at my quarto have a look at
my Dynamic docs uh I welcome any
suggestions
I'm gonna have to defer to someone else
on this
I can't just say webpage I think web
pages these days are I think folks have
been trained or expected that web pages
do update themselves right like we're
used to animations we're used to you
know the New York Times web pages have
interactive JavaScript in them that you
can manipulate and so I think web page
kind of communicates so if you want to
say like my quarter webpage if you're
looking to give us a little bit of Mind
share we'd appreciate it but like I I
actually just use web page or my website
that I built with quarto or something
like that but I don't my hope is that
quarto is powerful enough to sort of
stay out of your way and let you theme
in whichever way you want so that it
looks great but in some sense if you
want to make something that is so
customizable people wouldn't even know
it's quarter it's just incredible right
I want you to build the best web pages
you can uh Notch the quarto web pages
that look like quarto I hope our quarter
Pages look good but the the goal is for
you to be able to make the best
technical content that you can
well thank you team so so much uh really
appreciate you answering all these
questions
um we have I know that there are a ton
more and I'm sure that we can get
together share them with you and you
know just continue the conversation for
the last closing questions that we have
is how do you release quarto uh how do
folks know what's the latest and if they
want to stay up to date where do they go
I think the best place to check is just
the quarto.org website so we do keep
that we keep that quarter.org website up
to date at all times there's always a
release which is the last is the most
recent stabilized version uh and then
there is always a pre-release available
um and that is basically hot off the
presses
um we work very hard to make those
prereleases very stable um and so we do
we do try to make those sort of use user
runnable at all times but those are not
off the presses and so from time to time
we will let something slip into those
pre-releases that maybe maybe doesn't
deserve to be in there so use those with
a little bit of caution but that said
like I said you know we we run them all
the time that's what we anticipate yeah
we really work hard to try to make those
high quality so uh don't be don't be
terrified of them uh even though they're
they're they're fresh okay well thank
you hope everybody has a wonderful day
and they can really appreciate
everything thank you all thank you all
for joining us this has been great it's
been great thank you